- [Narrator] On September 16th,
22 year old Mahsa Amini died
after being detained for
allegedly violating Iran's laws
requiring women to wear a headscarf.
Iranian authorities say
she died of illness,
but her family said she fell into a coma
after being mistreated by police.
Protests sparked by her death
have since rallied groups
across Iran's society
from ethnic minorities
to school children, and even oil workers.
According to human rights groups,
clashes with police have
killed more than 200 people.
But despite the crackdowns
and widespread internet shutdowns,
videos have continued to emerge,
showing how unrest has
spread beyond women's rights
to a movement that is calling for an end
to strike theocratic rule.
These demonstrations have now turned
into the most broadly
supportive movement in Iran
in more than four decades.
A day after her death,
Amini's funeral took place
in her hometown of Saqqez.
The ceremony quickly turned into a protest
against the country's morality police.
Mourners took off their headscarves
in defiance of the very rules Amini
was accused of breaching.
Amini was Kurdish Iranian,
part of an ethnic minority
that has long accused the government
of discrimination and neglect.
After a week of unrest,
authorities launched strikes
at Kurdish militant groups
across the border in Iraq
saying they were inciting the protests.
Although there were no
visible separate slogans
in the protests that
followed Amini's death.
And the demonstrations
against Iran's strict Islamic
dress code took on a new form.
On September 20th, a woman
in the eastern city of
Kerman removed her headscarf
and cut her hair in a video
that was widely shared online.
It triggered a wave of
support from around the world
with celebrities and women
imitating her gesture
and posting videos to social media.
That's roughly when the
government restricted access
to the internet in large
parts of the country.
Access to platforms like
Instagram and WhatsApp
that have been used to
organize rallies was blocked.
The internet cuts through
criticism from businesses.
Tehran's Chamber of
Commerce estimated the cost
of $24 billion for industries
including IT services.
But despite the restrictions,
the protestors message
was taken up by students
across the country.
In one case, children
at an all girls school
took off their scarves
and chased away a man
from the premises,
throwing bottles and chanting shameless.
As more crowds took to the
streets in large numbers,
the government used tear
gas and live ammunition
to disperse demonstrations.
A particularly deadly incident
broke down the southeast,
home to another ethnic
minority, the Baluch.
On September 30th, protestors were seen
walking towards a police
station before being fired upon.
Local human rights groups
say more than 90 people
were killed in what protestors
dubbed "bloody Friday."
The government blamed the
violence on a local militant group
that has denied any role in the protests.
And then demonstrations spread
to one of the most critical
sectors of Iran's economy, oil.
In early October, workers went on strike
at a number of refineries,
blocking roads with stones
and chanting slogans in
support of other protests.
Although the government
claimed these strikes
weren't related to Amini's death.
These strikes highlight
another big problem
for the Islamic republic,
a struggling economy due to US sanctions
and a number of other
issues in the country
and they have a symbolic weight in Iran.
It was strikes to oil refineries in 1978,
much bigger ones than today
that helped bring down the Shah of Iran,
Mohammad Reza Pahlavi,
in the revolution that established
the current Islamic republic.
In recent years Iran's leaders
have faced several protest movements,
but have shown no sign of backing down
and today is no different.
They claim the demonstrations
are being orchestrated
by foreign enemies,
and hundreds of protestors
have been brought to trial.
But discontent has continued to emerge
across society disrupting normal life.
From this prison that was engulfed by fire
after a clash between
detainees and prison guards
to shopkeepers striking across the country
and a major target of the demonstrations
continues to be one of the foundations
of the theocratic state.
Its Supreme leader, Ali Khamenei.
(crowd chanting)